Çeviri: Gözde Caymazer
Gözden geçirme: Sancak Gülgen
Judith Liberman
Masal Anlatıcısı
Evet, arkadaşımızın söylediği gibi
masal anlatıcısıyım.
Bugünkü bölümü bana
masal anlatma zaten.
Çoğu zaman masal anlatıcısı
olduğumu söylediğim zaman, birkaç
kaşlar kalkıyor böyle, hmmm.
Biri bana dedi ki ‘’Bu ne?
Yeni bir şey mi çıktı?’
''Yoo'' dedim, ''tam tersi,
modası geçmiş bir iş yapıyorum.
''Geçti, geri getirmeye çalışıyoruz.''
Yoksa benden daha iyi biliyorsunuz,
çok yakın bir zamana kadar bu topraklarda
köyden köye gezen bir çok masalcı vardı.
Aşıklar, dengbejler, meddahlar.
''Anlatıcılık nedir?'' diye soracak
olursanız, aslında bir sanat dalı.
Hepimizin her gün, hepinizin her gün
kullandığınız bir sanat dalıdır.
İnsan olarak bizim, başka birine bir şey
gördürme ve hissettirme yeteneğimiz var.
Çok acayip bence.
Örneğin ressam.
Nereye götürsem sizi?
Hmm.
Desem iki sene önce, Hindistan'a
gittim masal anlatmak için.
Akşamüstü dev bir hindistan cevizi
ormanın ortasındayız.
Küçük bir binanın çatısının üstündeyiz.
Çatı düz, üstüne bir sürü minder koyduk
ve elli kişi uzanıp masal dinliyor.
Bizde hayali yola çıktık.
Kahramanın peşinden gidiyoruz.
Onunla beraber çöle gidiyoruz,
onunla beraber kasabaya gidiyoruz.
Ve birden, kahraman nurdan
bir kubbeye girdi.
Kahraman yukarıya bakmış,
ve bizde yukarıya baktık.
Yalnız yukarıya bakınca o gece,
biz göğü gördük.
Ve o gece gök, ince bir beyaz bulut
tabakasıyla kaplıymış.
Ve dolunay, onun arkasında
bütün bulutları aydınlatıyordu.
O gece biz de nurdan bir kubbenin altında
olduğumuzu gördük ve büyülendik.
Ve ben size bunu anlattığım zaman, aynı
zamanda beden olarak burada olabilirsiniz.
Aynı zamanda hindistan cevizi
ormanını görebilirsiniz.
Aynı zamanda minder
üstünde uzanabilirsiniz.
Ya da nurdan bir kubbe görebilirsiniz.
Bu çok, yani bu insanoğlunun inanılmaz
güzel, olağanüstü bir yeteneği.
Ve anlatıcılık bu yeteneğe dayalı,
dayanan sanattır.
Ve ben yedi senedir Türkiye’de bu sanatı
yeşertmek için tohumlar ekiyorum.
Bu gün sizinle o yolda öğrendiğim
birkaç şeyi paylaşmak isterim.
Şimdi her hikaye belli bir yer,
belli bir zamanda başlar.
Bugün size anlatacağım hikaye,
20 sene önce başlıyor.
Paris'teyim, 17 yaşındayım.
Bu size bugünkü yaşımı söylüyor.
Ve küçücük bir lokantaya gidiyorum,
sıra ışı bir lokanta.
Adı Legre de Barbaric.
O lokantaya tam yedi buçukta gidilir.
Kapı daha önce kapalı.
Yemekler tam sekizde veriliyor.
Otuz metrekarelik mekan içinde,
zar zor kırk kişi sığıyor, tıklım tıkış.
Garson masaların arasından zor geçiyor.
Zaten sipariş almak zor değil.
Çünkü herkes aynı yemeği
yiyor lokantada, öyle.
Kahveleri bitirince dükkan sahibi
laterna çıkartıyor.
Ve başlıyor tü tütü tü tütü.
Ve şarkı söylüyor.
Dürüdüdü dirü dü dirü.
Ve bizi şarkı söylemeye davet ediyor.
Birbirimize bakıyoruz.
Sizi yapacağımı zannediyorsunuz,
şimdi korkmaya başladınız.
Hayır.
İster misiniz?
Ve birbirimize bakıyoruz, kimisi şarkı
söylemeye başlıyor, kimisi istemiyor,
ama patron buna izin vermiyor.
Herkes söylüyor ve bir an sonra hepimiz
birbirimize bakıp gülerek şarkı söylüyoruz.
Amaan.
Ve o an bir lokantaya giden bir takım
yabancılar olmaktan çıkıp,
birbirine bakan, bağlı olan
bir toplum oluyoruz.
Aslında bu dükkan sahibi bir büyücü.
Bizi oradan seyrediyor, hazırlıyor
ve doğru kıvama getirdiğinde,
ışıklar azalıyor, laterna yok oluyor.
Yerinde küçücük bir tabure var.
Taburenin üstünde ufacık bir kadın.
Mimi Barthelemy.
Fransa'nın en meşhur
masalcılarından biri.
Bu gece onu dinlemek için toplandık.
Çünkü Mimi Barthelemy bir masalcı.
Çünkü Legre de Barbaric
masalcıların lokantasıdır.
Ve Mimi başladı.
''Mösyö madam la sosyette.''
Dakikalar sonra benim için
lokanta yok olmuştu.
Ben Güney Amerika’da derede
kürek çekiyorum.
Etrafımda yağmur ormanlarının yeşilleri
beni sarıyor.
Ağaçlar kocaman dallarını
göğe doğru uzatıyor.
Daldan dala maymunlar zıplıyor.
Ben de onların peşine gidiyorum.
Anahtar onlarda.
Onlar çaldılar, onu yakalamam lazım.
Masal bitince, kendimi birden daracık
bir Paris lokantasının içinde buldum.
Ve şey olmuştum,
'Burası neresi? Neredeyim? '
Çünkü o gece hayalim
gerçekliğini geçmişti.
Çok derin bir masal transa geçirmiştim.
Ben de iki sene sonra Paris’te
konservatuvarda anlatıcılık
bölümüne yazıldım ve ondan sonra ben de
okullarda, kitap evlerinde, hastanelerde
masal anlatmaya başladım.
Sonra bir gün hayatımda güçlü bir rüzgar
geldi, beni buraya taşıdı.
Türkiye’de.
Önce Türkçe'yi öğrenmem gerekti.
Ondan sonra burada da masal
anlatmaya devam ettim.
Ve bu bütün süre boyunca benim için
o gece o lokantada
benim deneyimlediğim şey
benim için bir pusula oldu.
Dinleyicilerime o gece yaşadığım
deneyimi yaşatmak istiyordum.
O büyüyü paylaşmak istiyordum.
Belki de o yüzden İstanbul’da yarattığım,
düzenlediğim ilk masal gecesi,
daracık bir mekandaydı,
yaz evinde, Kadıköy’de.
Yemek vermiştik.
Masal anlatmadan önce biraz akordeon
çalıp herkese şarkı söylettirmiştim.
Çünkü aynı deneyimi yaratmak istiyordum.
Ama küçücük başladığımız bu masal geceleri
çok hızlı büyümeye başladı.
Gelen bir daha geliyor,
arkadaşını getiriyor.
Başka mekanlara taşınmak zorunda kaldım.
Masallarımı çantama koydum
ve bir sürü başka yerlere gittim.
Son birkaç senede yüzlerce
masal geceleri düzenledim.
Yirmi kişilik, bin kişilik gruplara kadar.
Okullarda, sahilde, ateş etrafında,
kültür merkezinde, tiyatroda,
İş Kule'nin son katında, Bienal'de,
yoga merkezinde.
Biraz her şeyi denedim.
Hatta NTV Radyo’da kendi masal programımı
yapmaya başladım.
Ve sinema filminde bir masal anlattım.
Ve bunların hepsini yaptıktan sonra
şunu keşfettim.
Bu sihirli yolculuğa beraber gitmek
için, yani hayalimizin gerçekliğimizi
geçmesi için yemek şart değilmiş.
Yani ondan önce verebilirsiniz,
ondan sonra verebilirsiniz.
Masal boyunca odak dağıtıyor.
Işık? Işık konusunda çok
bir kural bulamadım.
Yani loş bir ışık güzel, ama önemli olan
şimdiki gibi birbirimizi görebilmektir.
Peki müzik?
Müzik kesinlikle çok hoş
bir ambians katıyor.
Ama o da şart değil.
Peki önemli olan nedir?
Bence önemli olan bir araya gelip,
aynı mekanda hayal kurmaktır.
Teknolojinin yapamayacağı
bazı şeyler var.
En gelişmiş iletişim teknolojimiz olsa da,
hala bir araya gelmeye ihtiyacımız var.
Hala aynı odada, aynı havayı soluyup,
bir birimize bakarak,
hayal kurmamız gerekiyor.
Masal gecelerinde yüz elli kişi bir çatı
altında hayali yollara düşüyoruz.
Ve beraber gittiğimizde
hayallerimiz daha renkli oluyor.
Hayali yollara daha uzak,
daha derin gidiyoruz.
Bir odada hayal ettiğimizde
odadan bir dalga yayılıyor.
Bir odak dalgası,
bir hayal dalgası.
O an birbirimize uyumlanıyoruz,
o an birbirimize bağlanıyoruz.
Masallar isterseniz kitaplarda
okuyabilirsiniz, filmde seyredebilirsiniz,
radyoda dinleyebilirsiniz.
Ama aynı odadan dinlemek, aynı odada
hayal kurmak farklı bir şey.
Ve bence bizim eski toplumlarımızın
yaptığı gibi bir araya gelip,
beraber hayal kurmaya
hala ihtiyacımız var.
Ancak o zaman bir toplum oluyoruz.
Ancak o zaman birleşip, beraber barış
içinde yürümeye başlayabileceğiz.
Şimdi diyebilirsiniz ‘‘aa tamam,
toplanalım, uyumlanalım, anlatalım,
ama ne anlatalım?’’.
Bence herhangi bir hikaye kullanabiliriz
uyumlanmak için.
Ama bence masal anlatmamız gerekiyor.
O da neden diyeceksiniz.
Masalların özel bir görevi var.
Bize hayatımızın noktalarını farklı
bir biçimde birleştirmeyi öğretiyorlar.
Şöyle.
Sabah evden çıkıyorsun,
metrobüse biniyorsun.
Metrobüse binen var mı burada?
Yok.
Çok güzel arabalar gördüm gelirken de,
o yüzden merak ettim.
Metrobüse biniyorsunuz.
Tıklım tıkış.
Hatırlarsanız. Alanlar var.
Tıklım tıkış ve metrobüs tam boğaza
giderken trafiğe takılıyor.
Burnunuz tam bir adamın
koltuk altına denk geliyor.
Kafanızı çeviriyorsunuz.
O an boğazdan geliyorsunuz,
ahh, İstanbul.
Ve bir martı bir balığı kapmış,
pencerenin önünden uçuyor.
Dönüyorsunuz, teyzeyle göz
göze geliyorsunuz.
O da gördü, gülüşüyorsunuz.
Trafik açılıyor, otobüs geliyor.
Durağında bir tane amca, şey satıyor,
bu köpük baloncuk tabancalardan.
Kapıda açıldığı zaman bir
bulut baloncuk giriyor.
Baloncukların hepsi patlıyor,
ama bir tanesi var.
O bir tane baloncuk, otobüs devam ederken
patlamadan otobüsün arkasına doğru,
herkesin kafasının üstünde
uçmaya devam ediyor.
Ve bir daha ki durağa gelince kapı da
açılıyor, patlamadan çıkıyor.
İşe gidiyorsunuz,
nefis bir çay sizi bekliyor.
Ayşe Teyze var ya, hiç kimse
onun gibi yapmıyor.
Yanında biri pasta getirdi.
Browni. Süper, tam ihtiyacınız.
Şey yazdı, "Mutlu Pazartesi"
Çok tatlı.
Tadına bakıyorsunuz, bu ne?
İş arkadaşınız geliyor, şey yapıyor.
‘‘Ay vegan brownimin tadına baktın mı?
İnanır mısın içinde yağ yok, şeker yok,
çikolata yok, yumurta yok.’’
‘‘Yapma yaa. Ne var içinde?’’
‘‘Barbunya.’’
‘’Süper, tarifini verirsin değil mi?’’
falan.
''Ben ofisime gidiyorum şimdi.''
Bilgisayarı açıyorsunuz, 150 mail.
Okumanıza zaman yok,
çünkü toplantıya geç kaldınız.
Gidiyorsunuz, toplantıda "slayt ile ölüm",
150 slayt sizi bekliyor.
Masanın altından Facebook açıyorsunuz.
Mora'nın yeni bebek fotoğrafları var.
Böyle devam ediyor, gün boyunca.
Gökçe ile sohbetler, işler, dead line.
Akşam geliyorsunuz neler gördünüz,
kokladınız, hissettiniz,
düşündünüz, okudunuz.
Ve eşiniz, çocuğunuz, kediniz, evde kim
bekliyorsa size soruyor.
''Ee, bugün nasıl geçti?''
O an ne anlatıyorsunuz?
Her şeyi anlatamıyorsunuz,
fazla zaman alır.
Yok, o an birkaç noktaları
seçiyorsunuz dört beş tane
ve onları birleştiriyorsunuz.
Ve birleştirmek için kullandığınız
malzeme ne? Bu ip ne?
Bu ip, bir hikaye.
O an ne anlatıyorsunuz?
Dikkat et, çünkü o an içinde
yarattığın gerçekliği yaratıyorsun.
Şunu mu anlatıyorsun?
Yeter artık yav.
Üç saat trafikte geçirdim bugün,
millet deodorant kullanmıyor,
iğrenç pasta yapıyor, 150 mail ,
150 slayt, öleceğimi zannettim.
Bu hayat hayat değil yemin ederim,
Bodrum'a taşınıyorum.
Siz de taşınıyorsunuz.
Teşekkürler.
Anlaşılan burada iki bin kişinin
Bodrum'a taşınma planı var.
Ya da şey mi anlatıyorsunuz?
Yaa, bugün Ayşe Teyze'nin çayı yaa.
Müthiş yaa, bu kadın bir melek,
kimse onun gibi yapmıyor.
Bir de Gökçe var ya, üff.
Öğle yemeğinde beni o kadar çok güldürdü
ki ayran içerken burnumdan ayran çıktı ya.
Anlattığın buysa, hikayen dostluk bağlantı
dolu olursa hayatında öyle olur.
Peki akşam şey mi anlatıyorsun.
Bugün boğazdan geçerken bir martı
gördüm, tam balık kapmıştı.
Bu baloncuk patlamadı, bir de Mora’nın
yeni bebeğinin fotoğrafları,
böyle bir gülümseme, ayy tam bir mucize.
Anlattığın buysa, hikayen sihir ve hayret
dolu olursa hayatın da öyle olur.
Hayatımız, onu yaşarken değil
onu anlatırken yaratıyoruz.
Anlatmadıklarını unutursun.
Altı gün önce öğle yemeğinde ne yedin,
anlatmamışsan hatırlamıyorsun.
İşte sorun şu ki bazı hikayelerin
içinde kayboluyoruz.
Hep aynı hikayeyi anlatırsak, başka bir
dünyanın mümkün olduğunu unutuyoruz.
Ve bu toplumda, bu modern toplumda,
içinde kaybolduğumuz bir hikaye var.
Yaygın, bulaşıcı bir hikaye.
Kıtlık, hırs, tüketim, korku.
Ve bu hikayeden nasıl çıkacağız?
İşte o noktada masallar bize
yardıma koşuyor.
Masallar sıradan metinler değil.
Binlerce senedir gönülden ağza,
ağızdan kulağa, kulaktan gönüle,
süzüle süzüle bize gelen
şifalı simgesel yolculuktur.
Masallarda kahraman bilen değil, yok.
Kahraman plansız yola bir adım atan,
risk alan kişidir.
Masallarda aşk kazanır.
Masallarda son ekmek lokması paylaşılır.
Masallarda en küçük kazanır.
Ve kuyunun dibine düştüğümüzde
yeni sihirli dünyalar keşfederiz.
Ve onları dinlerken biz de
bunu yaşıyoruz.
Ve o an sinapslar içinde, beynimiz içinde
yeni noktalar birleşiyor.
Masallar atalarımızın sesidir.
Kulağımıza fısıldıyor.
Hayatımızı yeniden yorumlamaya çağırıyor.
Hayat yolumuzu farklı bir
şekilde çizmeyi öğretiyor.
Bu da kahramanın yolu.
Ve onu takip ederek içinde kaybolduğumuz
karanlık ormandan çıkış yolunu buluruz.
İşte o yüzden ben, birkaç
senedir İstanbul’da her ay,
ve bir çok farklı şehirde
masal geceleri düzenliyorum.
Bir araya gelmek için, farklı bir dünyanın
mümkün olduğunu hatırlamak için,
ve ona giden yolu beraber
hayal etmek için,
Ve sen de bir masalcısın.
Bugün kime, hangi masalı anlatacaksın?
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)